a friend of mine told me that sex and
gender are different sex being
biological and gender being more fluid
and social true or BS kinda yeah
so so if you like writing 18 books on
this no I think we got we got one
sentence well so okay go for the one
sentence one sense is gender is the
software of sex does that make it more
flexible yes
but gender is the software of sex gives
us the correct inference which is that
this is not a completely free variable
this is also subject to evolutionary
pressures and evolutionary history there
is much more reason to expect variation
between populations and how this
parameter functions
there's also reason to expect that we
have more room going forward to change
gender than we do sex but the to say
that gender and sex are different is not
to say the thing that is usually implied
when people invoke that which is that
gender is an arbitrary landscape that we
are free to choose you recognize that
wasn't one sentence right there was one
that was about the eight sentences I was
going to say about let me let me also
say you know I have written about this a
fair bit already and spoken about it in
various places in non-human organisms
the thing that we call gender in humans
we call sex role and it's effectively
the behavioral component that is mostly
predictable from what sex you are and so
for instance in the much trotted out by
the trans rights activists generally not
what I call true trans but in the trans
rights activists like to point out
hermaphrodite xx switching fish
sequentially hermaphroditic fish reef
fish like clown fish and damsel fish and
such which as if that suggests that
people can do the same thing and of
course it means no such thing but what
happens in these fish is for depending
on the ecology of the particular species
at the point that a male switches to a
female actually switches to a female
goes from producing sperm to producing
ovaries has anatomical and physiological
changes that accompany that that are
also about the sex but also changes the
behavior from male typical behavior to
female typical behavior and the behavior
is the gender it's the sex role so are
there things that men and women do that
are sex typical sex stereotypical if you
wish that that are true across cultures
yeah less so across all cultures then
within cultures are the things that we
behaviorally do that aren't absolutely
mandated by our anatomy and physiology
like breast feeding and just dating and
ejaculating and things like this are
things that are behaviorally following
from sex more flexible and malleable
than sex itself for sure but of course a
lot of the trans ideology that is being
trotted out suggests that the behavior
is the same so I mean they're they're
doing a kind of a mountain Bailey thing
where they claim oh we're only talking
about gender and then they'll also claim
in the next breath that sex isn't real
either so sex and gender are different
but gender follows from sex and yes we
can unhook some of the traditional
expectations of gender roles like this
usually that's not in the room we can
unhook some of the traditional
expectations of gender roles as we come
to understand why they're there
[Music]